today we have a big one it's time for
the year in preview video for the year
2023. after all the only proper thing to
do after an eventful 2022 is to keep the
momentum going what better way to do
that than to give us sequels to some of
the most popular titles as well as green
lighting anime adaptations of the
hottest manga and novels in town so now
let's take a look at some titles that
ought to keep us looking forward let me
tell you as early as now 2023 looks to
be as star-studded as any other year
with a lot of titles that I'm sure a lot
of you can't wait to watch we start the
list off in full overdrive with Tokyo
Avengers season 2.
Tokyo Avengers didn't waste any time
making a name for itself in the anime
Community combining the time Loop plot
line with badass street gangs ended up
being a winning formula and people just
can't get enough of Mikey and the rest
of the doorman as such the second season
was all but guaranteed and we're getting
it sooner rather than later this January
specifically this time Tokyo Avengers
will Chronicle the Christmas conflict
Arc this Arc pits the doorman against
black dragon and the Sheba family more
intense fights and more gripping drama
awaits as Dragon finally gets his time
to shine in this Arc it's a holiday
special like no other coming this
January 2023
and if sequels on your jam how about an
adventure Thriller in Hell's Paradise
one of the rising stars in the manga
world is about to make an impact in the
anime sphere hell's Paradise is quite an
honest title for what to expect starring
a ninja who just can't seem to die his
immortality gets put to the test in a
journey to an island of peril along with
the rest of the convicts Gabi Maru the
hollow looks to bring home the elixir of
life and along with it his freedom an
island believed to be paradise hides in
it dangers Beyond anyone's wildest
imagination this Dark Adventure looks to
make its mark this 2023 bringing with it
Mysteries and engaging characters that
people can think of all throughout its
run it's looking to be a memorable hit
this 2023 the rating is more than
fitting too as this isn't your everyday
shown unfair
speaking of exploration how about some
more Dr Stone
it's been a while but it's nice to see
Dr Stone making a comeback with the
stonewalls behind us it's time to go
exploring thus Dr Stone's third season
looks to take us on a journey around the
world with the manga's acclaimed Age of
Exploration Arc we actually got a
special that bridged the two seasons not
too long ago and it only made people
anticipate what's to come even more this
season will Mark the characters foray
into the other side of the world and
finally start making some Headway into
understanding a very important
phenomenon petrification yes at least
we'll be getting some information on the
grand Catalyst of the story and like
everything else it's a discovery that
I'm very eager to see the characters
uncover Dr Stone is set to make its big
return this spring 2023
foreign
also makes its much awaited return this
2023
this one shouldn't come as a surprise
it's not every day you see a studio
being created for the sake of adapting a
single series but that should cue you in
on how all in the industry is going on
mushoku tensei they've said that they
plan to adapt the entire series and
knowing the number of volumes that there
are we won't be saying goodbye to rudius
and the rest of dead end anytime soon
mushoku tensei has already made a huge
impact with its first season generating
as much bars as fans could possibly hope
to have but the second season comes the
next phase of Rudy's Adventure
adolescence want new challenges and
encounters away in his continued quest
to learn more about magic in the world
for those who can't get enough of
mushoku tensei 2023 or to be a great
year for you all
another show to get excited about
Rurouni Kenshin
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you heard that right after multiple live
action movies ovas and other material it
seems that they're still a demand for
more Kenshin thus the Timeless classic
is set to make its big return in 2023.
it's quite a pleasant surprise because
like Shaman King not too long ago the
roroni Kenshin TV series never had a
proper ending as far as adapting the
manga's end is concerned animated by
linden films this new anime will be
re-adapting the manga bringing it up to
speed with modern animation and a brand
new cast it's gonna be yet another
addition to Linden film's growing resume
and it's looking like their best project
to date if you weren't around in the 90s
you'll finally get to see a modernized
version of the Timeless classic that's
captured the hearts and Imagination of
anime fans for decades it's one of the
best Shonen anime out there and newer
fans will finally get to experience the
tale for themselves
foreign
levelings getting its anime adaptation
sooner rather than later
[Music]
it's not too long when people have
brought up the prospect of a solo
leveling anime after seeing the webtoon
adaptations of 2020 I just think that
solo leveling getting an anime is the
next logical step and guess what we're
all correct a couple of months ago we
finally got the first trailer confirming
the adaptation of the action fantasy
Manoa and it was met with a lot of
excitement and that's probably an
understatement A1 pictures will be
handling this adaptation with some great
minds like hiroyuki Samano involved
there's a lot to be excited about the
adaptation of the plot is one thing but
in terms of production we can really
tell they're putting their eggs in the
basket for one of the most hyped up
pieces of Korean media out there for
those looking to get their first taste
of this super popular edgy weak to
strong series then now's your chance
solo leveling scheduled for a 2023
release
thank you
Demon Slayer also won't be left behind
as its new season comes in in fourth
place
[Music]
don't let anyone tell you that the hype
is over Demon Slayer looks to build on
the momentum of the previous excellent
Arc with his next season this time
featuring The swordsmith Village Arc the
previous season saw different pillars
make their Mark and this one's no
different this time it's missed pillar
muichiro donkito's turn to fight while
danger closes in on donjiro we also get
a reunion with genya who should prove
helpful in the fight against the
strongest upper moon tanjiro has to face
so far there's no confirmation but I
think UFO table maybe went on the way to
adapting the entire Demon Slayer manga
into anime I mean why wouldn't they win
the thing basically prints money expect
them to bring the A Plus game to this
season just as they always do and given
the intensity of the fights that we've
got in store this is going to be one
glorious season to watch
foreign
third most anticipated anime we have Jiu
Jitsu Kaizen
Jiu Jitsu Kaizen has quickly become a
fan favorite thanks to its interesting
magic system likable characters and
spectacular fights it didn't take too
long for the title to become one of the
most popular Shonen anime in the past
few years after the first season ended
with a bang fans were wanting more and
they sure got it why start with Jiu
Jitsu Kaizen zero when we can have an
entire season two the second season
takes us to the Shibuya Arc and as
someone who read the Manga I'd say it's
the most engaging Arc so far fights get
turned up to 11 and the stakes man
they've never been higher than before if
you thought season one was intense wait
till you see what's in store as the
strongest curse spirits and cursed users
unite in their quest to unleash hell you
won't need to wait for too long though
for the continuation of the epic battle
Shonen as this second season will be
coming this 2023
villain Saga season 2 is up next
I've got nothing but praise for Finland
Saga and I'll be the first one to share
how excited I am for the second season
the first one's been an extremely
engaging tale of Adventure and conquest
and not only that I've also learned
quite a bit from it however the second
season looks to depart from that and
have a slow steady approach with showing
us its world I think it only speaks to
the versatility of Finland Saga it's not
always about fighting and adventuring
and even with the change of tone Finland
Saga has continued to be as engaging as
before it's a story about Redemption and
we're sure to see some major changes in
torfin after the events of the first
season people who love nuanced character
arcs will have a blast here we only have
to wait until January for the much
awaited continuation to one of 2019's
best animes it's being handed over to
mapper so let's cross our fingers and
see what mapper will bring to the table
[Applause]
[Music]
speaking of which shows being handed
over to mapa what else better to finish
this list off then Attack on Titan's
final season
yes it's finally coming to a close for
real this time Attack on Titan needs
little introduction being one of the
most popular and iconic anime to come
out in the last decade or so it's given
us a roller coaster of emotion since
then and I can't believe that it's
finally time for the whole thing to end
or will it I don't know maybe they'll
put out a super short run this time to
put out a final season part four on us
or something like that either way
there's not much to be said besides how
everyone seems super excited to finally
see the ending come in anime form this
is it the long journey has come to an
end and we've seen firsthand how
experiences and Revelations have shaped
the journeys of our main characters
Aaron Mikasa and armin's story comes to
a climax in this dramatic conclusion
thank you 2023 is where it's at and
where it all ends the world is watching
in anticipation as to how this long
ethic will wrap up and whatever happens
at the end is sure going to be the Talk
of the Town
foreign
tube social media in the description box
I'll be back with more videos so don't
forget to subscribe and be the first in
life once again thank you and I'll see
you next time